Go ahead, brother. Simple. Um, I have I
have a couple questions because I'm
trying I'm trying to compare the the
words of Christ and I'm hearing a lot of
people say that Christianity is um
pacifist and I'm studying the Crusades
at
I know, I know, I know. And I'm looking
at the Crusades. I'm reading um Raymond
uh Abraham, the Defenders of the West,
right? Phenomenal. I I can't put it
down. The the issue right now is I'm
trying to I'm trying to com I'm trying
to coincide both ideas together but I I
need help. That that's the issue. Okay,
brother. First step, I've done some
sessions on it and first step when Roman
centurions, by the way, here's Raymond
Ibrahim. I may have to invite him.
Rabbin Ibrahim is a Middle Eastern
Christian. He's one of the most
knowledgeable Christians on Islam and
jihad, exposing Islam. Yeah, he's on
shows with David Wood. He's one of the
originals. Yeah, sadly he doesn't get
enough attention and sadly I I haven't
mentioned him enough because
I have forgotten about him to my shame.
But here is Raymond Ibraim. I just
subscribed. I'm going to reach out to
him. Bring him on. He even has See, turn
the other cheek. See, he even has such
see what does that mean? All right. So,
you can see he's also like William. He
loves the gym, but unlike William, he's
buffed and muscular. But put that aside.
Now, does the Bible call us to be
pacifists? Well, obviously the Old
Testament doesn't do that, right? Not at
all. But in the New Testament, well, we
got a problem with the New Testament.
Number one, historical context of the
New Testament. The church
is living under the rule of Roman
tyranny. Correct? Yes. Okay. There are
going to be two questions you're going
to need to answer to understand the the
answer to what you asked me. First of
all,
when Roman centurions, soldiers,
converted, can you show anywhere in the
New Testament where they were told, "Now
that you're Christians, you can no
longer be soldiers fighting for a pagan
empire." It doesn't say that. That's
number one. This would have been the
most obvious thing to do. Say, "Hey, not
only we Christians, we don't believe in
just war or appropriate force, even a
means having to put people to death to
protect people's lives. But you are
fighting for a pagan empire. Yes. And
you're going to be having to kill people
for this pagan empire that is completely
uncristlike. And if you don't step down,
we won't baptize you. You don't find
that, do you? I'm I've been looking for
it. They can't find it. It's not there.
Okay. Okay. So, that's that's one.
Secondly,
when the church finds itself at a time
in a situation where now the entire
land is now governed by Christians,
meaning we're no longer under a
situation where you have pagans ruling
the land. It's now in the hands of
Christians. Now, these Christians want
to make sure God blesses the land. Yeah.
So they must look to
a biblical model model a paradigm to
model the form of government
to establish that will be pleasing to
God. So where do they look to
um I'm I'm still I'm still studying. So
they look to Christ.
Well, obviously Christ, but where where
are you going to find how to establish a
form of government that will legislate
the Romans? No, pagans. Really? The
pagans? No, no, no. Not the pagans.
Forgive me. Forgive me. Because this is
this is something I'm struggling with.
Where would they have to turn to? They
would have to turn to I I believe the
Bible. I'm I'm I'm guessing. Where? What
part of the Bible? brother stuck for
Allah
they would have to turn to either I
can't you might have to help me not
really you know the answer you're just
nervous I am where would they have to
look to to know to legislate establish a
form of government in which they now
legislate according to God's will oh the
old testament obviously because in the
old testament that was a theocracy Yes.
New Testament, the church is established
under Roman oppression.
Okay. So now the church is in control.
Now the church has political influence.
It can only look to the Old Testament to
know how would God expect a Christian
nation to govern the land under. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Cuz back because I
believe that Christ was with God back in
the Old Testament. Well, Christ is God,
but not the father. And he's the one who
is appearing. Like I just said earlier,
he's the one who's appearing to the Old
Testament saints, right? Yes. So when So
when they So when they tell me that, oh
well, Christ said to turn the other
cheek when you're slapped or when ma
Matthew on the hill or the um on the
mount. So why didn't Jesus turn the
other cheek when he got slapped?
He actually went he actually went into
the um to the No, no. Right here. Yeah.
John 18:22:23. And when he had said
this, one of the officers standing
nearby gave Jesus a slap, saying, "Is
that the way you answered thy priest?"
What? I never Okay. I'd never seen that
verse. Allah, you were too excited.
Brother
Jesus answered him, "If I have spoken
wrongly, bear witness of the wrong. But
if rightly, why do you strike me?" Why
didn't he turn the other cheek?
Okay. Okay. Okay. That helps because
I've been I've been having um cuz I'm
I'm I'm in school right now as well. I'm
studying theology, religious comparison.
Monastery. Better quit than live in a
monastery. Sir,
all right. Now, I'm going to ask you
another question.
Matthew 26:50-54.
And Jesus said to him, "Friend, do what
you have come for." Then they came and
laid hands on Jesus and seized him. And
behold, one of those who were with Jesus
stretched out his hand and drew out his
sword and struck the slave of the high
priest and cut off his ear. So Jesus
disciple had a sword.
Yes. Cuz also when he came down from the
prayer prayer mount, he told us to um
sell our cloak and buy a sword. Well, it
wasn't the prayer mount, but not the
prayer. Yeah, I'm close. What I'm trying
to say is
they have swords.
[Music]
Oh, okay. Are you sure? Because I don't
know if you're reading. I'm reading it.
I'm reading it. I I'll read it. And
behold, how could he cut off anyone's
ear if he doesn't have a sword?
I mean, you can clap all you want.
That's why you they call you a lazy
dude. Shoot a little bit. No, the issue
is I'm I'm I'm in religious comparisons
as well. So I'm studying two religions
at once and I'm trying and I hear these
debates. They the Muslims come to me.
Don't try too many religions one time.
You're going to go you're going to
confuse yourself. But listen to this.
That's true. Listen to this. Threw out
his sword and stuck the slave of the
high priest. So why were Jesus's
disciples carrying swords with them in
defense for defense? Why were they? If
Jesus is against bearing arms,
why? Because he's not he's not against
bearing arms. Now, second thing Jesus
did not say, I want you to if you catch
it. Then Jesus said to him, "Put your
sword back in its place." Why did he say
put it back in its place? Why didn't he
say get rid of it?
Because he wanted us to hold it to
defend ourselves. Oh, but he does say
you cannot impose the kingdom by
violence. If you live by the sword,
you're going to die by the sword. So,
though you can have a sword, he didn't
say get rid of it. Notice they have it.
All this time they're with Jesus. I
guess they didn't get the memo. They
still have a sword. And he doesn't say
get rid of it. He goes put it back in
its place. But you cannot use the sword
to force the kingdom of God upon people.
That you can't do. That's Muhammad. Do
you think that I cannot appeal to my
father and he will at once put at my
disposal more than 12 legions of angels?
Therefore, how will the scriptures be
fulfilled which say that it must happen
this way? How about the parallel in
John? Okay. Okay. John 18:7-11.
Therefore, he again asked them, whom do
you seek? And they they said, Jesus the
Nazarene. Jesus answered, I told you
that I am he. So, if you seek me, let
these go their way. Let them go. M
ordered that the word which he spoke
would be fulfilled. Of those who have
given me, I lost not one. Simon Peter
then having a sword. So now John tells
you who the disciple was. It was Simon.
Drew it and struck the high priest's
slave and cut off his right ear. And the
slave's name was Malcus. You got it
guys? John gives you details. Matthew
doesn't to tell you that disciple was
Peter. The person whose ear got cut off
was Malcus. So Jesus said to Peter, "Put
the sword into the sheath." Why didn't
he say, "Get rid of it?" Because they
need it. But I thought Jesus is a
pacifist.
You know, okay, this this this this
played my mind. Okay, this playing with
my mind a little bit. No, don't play
with your mind. It's not just not a
pacifist. The cup which the father has
given me shall I not drink. And if Jesus
is a pacifist, what do you do with John
23-1 17 or Mark 11, Matthew 21? He drove
out money changers with a band of cords,
started whipping him and flipping tables
over. Does that sound like a pass
pacifist Jesus? Not at all. That should
answer your question. What you're going
to do now, you're going to look into
Augustine and the just war theory.
Augustine and the just war theory. Just
type in August and just war. Find
whatever you can because Christians may
not know this. It was Christian
theologians, scholars
that were forced to come up with what
they call the just war theory. Meaning
now that the empire had become
Christian, yes, they had to then based
on scripture and principal scripture
come up with
the teaching of when is it just, when is
it right to go to war and subjugate
enemies. And you're going to see the
just war theory was a theory developed
polished by Christians long before
Islam. Does not say that you have to go
and by the sword force people become
Christian or slaughter them. The just
war theory simply teaches that you have
a right to help those who are oppressed
who cannot fend for themselves. So you
love the Lord. Yes. and you see a tyrant
and a bully oppressing people, making
their lives miserable, and you have the
means to then remove him and set them
free, it's your duty. So, if a nation
has to attack another nation because
there's a tyrant abusing people and
oppressing them and making their it's
your Christian duty to come to their aid
and it's also your Christian right to
make sure your lands, your homes, your
wives and children. I I dove into
Christianity right after I got out the
military and that's another reason why
this pacifism ideal um it really
affected me and I and I'm grateful for
you because I was really actually
struggling with this and that's why when
I found um Ibraham um and he was
bringing up the crusades and and they
really in and my in my um in my pre my
priest at the moment he's um liberal in
his heart I could tell but a traditional
Catholic church or whatever it is if
you're an Orthodox, get Orthodox. Okay?
If your priest is liberal, go find you a
diehard traditional
Orthodox Christian. Okay? Because
liberalism has spread like cancer in all
the churches. He's not reflecting the
historic teaching of the church. Because
if you ask your priest, say, "Augustine
is one of our blessed saints. Didn't he
and others come up with the just war
theory?" He's going to have to.
I'm grateful for you. Thank you so much.
And may God bless you and may you live a
long life. Well, you pray you and I stay
holy in love with Jesus and not shame
the Lord and we get healthy. And
brother, even America, if you go back
history, I'm not saying they're
Christians, they did implement
Judeo-Christian principles. Yes. Where
do you think the Second Amendment came
from if not from the biblical principles
that is a right to bear arm to save
yourself? And that comes from where
Jesus says, if you don't have a sword,
sell your cloak and buy one and say,
Lord, here's two. And you know what the
Greek says? What does it say? Please
that is sufficient. That it is
sufficient and his will be sufficient
and his all you need to protect yourself
from highway abandons. Luke 22 35 to 38.
38 it says it. Lord see look we got two
swords. Don't let him say oh well he
says oh that is enough already. Like oh
no no no. It says that's
sufficient for the task. And and I also
learned if if I may say I also learned
that um the the crusaders, the knights
of the Templar and all those were
actually first they were protectors of
those on the road to Jerusalem. They
were not they they were protected and
then it it became to a point where it
was no other way but to try and take
back Jerusalem for us to be able to go
and worship. Okay.
Pope urban speeches he says that that
theseans
who are servants of demons are going
around pillaging people and desecrating
holy shrines and keeping Christians from
them. It's our duty to go and fight for
our brothers. Now yes if you see the
word where he says and they said Lord
behold swords we have two. He said to
them enough it is
sufficient. That is sufficient.
Sufficient
econoistin. I don't right there. Ask
your Greek or orthodox say what does it
mean? It means it is sufficient. Yeah.
All you need for the task. What is that?
I'm struggling with Greek right now.
Man, just tell your priest to read it
for you. Allah.
All right. Here it is. Econos. That
means able, content, enough. Good. That
is good enough. That is sufficient. You
have all you need. Worthy. Okay.